here are the nominees for best live
action short film
alakachu take and run maria brindler and
nadine luchinger
the dress to deuce weishach and mate
the long goodbye anil carya and rizz
amid on my mind martin stronga hansen
and kim magnusson
please hold katie davila and levine
menecha
and the oscar goes to the long goodbye
hey everyone uh
i'm kind of pranging out to be honest
uh thank you so much to the academy for
this incredible honor
we made this film from a very very
personal place
i feel like this is proof that
you need to make what you feel you need
to make rather than what you think you
should make
i just want to
i know it's not very engaging but i'm
just going to thank some people
i'd just like to thank we transfer some
such tom gardner the producer amanda
james stuart bentley
astrid caroline um
i'd like to thank my mum and dad and my
brother and sister if that's all right
and
especially to lara and ray and remy our
kids
i love you
thank you
you know
in such divided times
we believe that the role of story is to
remind us that there is no us and them
there's just us
and this
this is for everyone who feels like they
don't belong anyone who feels that
they're stuck in a no man's land
you're not alone we'll meet you there
that's where the future is peace
you